[Music]
bable bable bable
[Music]
[Music]
never
remember
[Music]
Father's Day is around the corner great
gift for the man in your life if he has
kids or just you don't have that kids
buy somebody something on Father's Day
even if they not a father get $30 off a
90 day supply of the bevel shave system
when you visit get beveled comm slash
Hannibal give the gift of a smooth bump
free shave up
[Music]
starting it start it up start it up
start it up just start it up it start
the room storage those doors still up
[ __ ] doing stuff smaller boy oh boy oh
yeah what's up everybody
how's mine welcome to another episode it
has a rebel podcast Hannibal Burres
hello my name is Tony tre let's say you
say my name me being like yep yep see
but nah man it's gotta you know
introduce yourself man you know yes like
that yeah it's just yeah I think is I
think it's better I think it's better
you let me do with that again then all
right mmm apologize I'm your host
Hannibal Buress and I'm totally drew oh
you know what this is a different one we
are in we're in New York City
place I used to live
I don't live I still have my place it
but I don't I'm really living a lot at
all yeah it's just expensive storage
unit expensive storage unit of mostly
[ __ ] that I don't even use I'm storing a
bunch of [ __ ] I don't even really want
cuz I never am never home in Chicago and
st. I wish I had that thing from New
York except my cialis gathered from your
apartment in New York it just seems like
it's a storage unit for all your
sentimental sentimental items yeah only
guess six Xbox the think with all the
laminates from events I've been to a
couple trophies and awards and maybe
seven shirts that I really care about
yeah that's it no you got that big
sausage bag of laundry sausage bag of
laundry yeah it looked like it looked
like a sausage but it just filled with
laundry yeah I got a giveaway a bunch of
clothes that's mine I need to do a purge
yeah I need to do a purge of stuff I
hate it that's very
where the clutter is good for the mind
and you just you know it clears your
mind so it's good to get rid of [ __ ]
yeah but we're in a unique situation
right now cuz I you know needed a spot
to record and I reached out to a couple
people and so I want to thank the people
that gasps Digital letting us use this
space yes Digital thank you
they got a bunch of podcasts at least
Gomez podcasts sex drugs rock and roll
show roast masters podcast a bunch Dave
Smith's they got they got a bunch of
stuff going and this is a solid
production in here we're gonna put out
the video of this one got a bunch of
mics they got some cameras in here I was
gonna say the setup in here is very
podcast friendly and it's super Park as
well this is a professional setup it
feels high quality at screens and [ __ ]
they've got a producer over here Shannon
there's a different this is different
man yeah nice usually we sit and goddamn
at a table at a rap like a random air
being a random air B&B we set up some
mics and then we go like that this is I
feel like yeah I feel like I'm I'm Steve
Harvey or some [ __ ]
alright feel like I'm Howard started or
something you know kind of producer
everything is good yeah yeah New York
being back well I think it was just cuz
yesterday I had to go from Williamsburg
into Midtown in a car and that was
really nerve wrecking I think if you
haven't been in New York for a couple
months and then you go into Midtown
right away yeah you know what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] it's just pure chaos it is
really charming it was uh it was me
anxiety a little thing especially when
you're coming from North Carolina when
you coming from North Carolina and when
you come from Durham dharam
Durham North Carolina and you go to
midtown Manhattan yeah it was a bit much
and and I turned it to one of those you
know I turned into one shot I didn't
think I'd turn into I started to one of
those people that was like what is this
[ __ ] this city's is saying it's too
oh this noise Hardy's cars honking who
would ever want to live it this place is
chaotic I can't take it
I go opposite I feel like New York is at
my pace so as soon as I got off that
planet and people are just like moving
and rushing like I understand that I
need to get into this flow or get left
behind
and I'm like other cities she'd be like
this like you don't get the [ __ ] out of
the way you're gonna get run over you
get knocked over and that's just that's
my page that's how I am I'm kind of a
hectic dude though you know me
know I've turned into a country boy yeah
myspace yeah you my long view my
newspaper my snifter giving my cognac
and give me my grandkids playing on the
yard and give me my farm and some some
some livestock I'm gonna make my own
milk and make my own eggs go get some
eggs out there from the coop out there
now we'll make some eggs for dinner it
sounds like that mid thirties talk right
here uh-huh yeah man this city life you
know this city life ain't for me no more
you know this city life is chaotic is
this a bill just a big noisy no actually
it's just really Midtown that's just a
nightmare nipples chill Brooklyn's
pretty today huh
what's a vice yeah did DC's and Merrill
show that [ __ ] I walk to that [ __ ] walk
to it that was you know that down look
when I walked up I was a little late
when I walked up they had little lobby
downstairs yeah is that all employees or
is that just like like a vice chill spot
like what is was I don't know I didn't
ask it looked like I think that's mostly
employees so maybe they have a Vice cafe
yeah it's probably employees I don't
that doesn't seem efficient to use that
big of a space just half of people to
chill it but there was like a beer
brewing thing brewing thing and then
there was like a bar and back I'm just
like damn happy tapas [ __ ] to work here
yeah vice you know they got they got
money man yeah I used to they went from
being a goddamn toilet magazine into a
media conglomerate
toilet magazine toilet magazine just
magazines you specifically read while
you [ __ ] you a lot of times you go to a
bathroom you see a vice magazine back in
like early what to thousands of
something even up to several years ago I
mean it may be a coffee table
did you have a newsroom right how many
Peter did you notice subscribe to the
magazine I have to say they didn't have
some content that was worthwhile or
interesting but the magazine itself but
Vice back in the day wasn't like they
weren't as like hardcore news like they
are now right wasn't it more just like a
kind of a [ __ ] around kind of a
magazine it was yeah it was kind of you
know dirty humor yeah stories about
drugs and [ __ ] and that was that they
really flipped that they flew a [ __ ]
like Netflix flip flip that [ __ ] next
you just said DVDs to your house and he
send them back yeah they need this hope
for they just hope for the best on the
honor system if you send them back and
I've never got panel do you ever get
penalized for that [ __ ] I think so
see I never got if you didn't send him
back yeah like I figured
that's a horrible business model they
must lose a lot of money but I think cuz
it was something where I just did the
send it back and I feel like I kept all
getting emails from them on sales and
some [ __ ] like well I know when you're
if you changed credit card information
with the subscriber now yeah
and then you know they have it and in
the bill doesn't go through because they
don't have your new credit card info do
you always send that email that says
houston we have a problem they talk
about you he'll an info I don't know I
never subscribed in that flips cuz I
always just use my friends is really
yeah really really really yeah really
you just subscribe you don't subscribe I
got friends that just hook me up you see
you don't you know support the Arts is
what you see no my friends support the
arts you know I said I got an ethnic
subscription
[Music]
all right yeah no I uh I have friends
that always had it now it's like do you
want to use my account and I always
wanted by the HBO go to and all those
things like how today like if you give
out how deregulated yeah how do they
regulate I don't know different accounts
on my personal definitely I think I paid
for there to be more since when I got
the bill okay so I got the building and
all three apartments on my personal
count plus my mom plus me so five
different users on yeah so what am i yes
so one of my homies is paying for us so
yeah I support I support by using one of
his accounts yeah Moke fast man yeah
mogh Fest was great mug fests the
company make smoke synthesizers they
have a fest in Durham Durham North
Carolina
I like how you finally learn how to say
mogh but you have a you have a theory of
why they say mogh instead of Moog what I
was I think that's Marcus's theory was
Marcus's theory about the South the
mountains or something yeah they just
started saying it yeah Wow
mo mo and he just rolled with mo it was
a fun festival four days beautiful fast
four days at the festival I feel like
that was a groan for me I felt very
comfortable I'm on my festivals I feel
anxiety too many young people mm-hmm
lots of [ __ ] happened in I get I just
won't go back to the hotel and then
maybe check out this or that a little
bit of some of this and that but mo fest
was the perfect amount of festival I
would do do a festival like that every
year and the people there is attend the
attendance to were very cool and nerdy
like me I felt like I was amongst my own
sure mm-hmm
it's a good time let's recap it day by
day
okay we get there Thursday Thursday
evening
I'm scheduled to bring to live quietly
on stage that's right and and so with
chilling hanging out backstage it's how
live pulls up with his van and he says
what are you doing he's like why are you
here
he didn't know I was gathered to bring
him up but I just thought maybe I was
chilling yeah still maybe is a weird
place for me to be people yeah people
always say that to me I said it's gonna
be the name of my autobiography Hannibal
Burres what are you doing here what do
you yeah and then he proceeded to be
like yeah what is this bother like he
wasn't really sure what was going on and
then I said to him I said hey man this
is mob fest but you gotta say mogh not
Mook he's and he's like oh the keyboard
was a yeah and that was that was that
they were just I don't even think he
knew what he was doing yeah well I guess
some people like that what is just doing
the gig yeah where they have to the
manager or the tour manager so whoever
just gives the information be here go
there and then they just do this yeah
with some you know is occasionally you
know but yeah yeah he was definitely it
was an in-and-out situation for him we
were waiting to go I was waiting to go
on stage and somebody sad stage comes up
to me yeah I spoke to him already
there's a kid for it what's up man man I
saw your show in Raleigh and then maybe
15 minutes later when I'm on stage he
comes to me and says hey Hannibal did
you [ __ ] any of those ballerinas that
you had on the show in Raleigh and I
said that was s oh yeah so weird didn't
ask me man
your vibe shifted I saw your face drop
and you're just like
like you had you looked visibly upset
that's yeah you don't ask it though I
ask you don't ask that like it's just
such a cause first of all we're sad
stage at a festival I'm getting ready to
perform oh I don't know you and you
that's what you that's what you asked me
I don't know if I were I'm trying to
think I'm gonna think and that'd be a
hypocrite and think about scenarios that
I've been as an appropriate was surely
have to have happen to be it been out
there somehow yeah
so I try to have some sort of empathy
and that be on my high horse but I don't
know if I ask somebody that while I'm
working out right before you know what
I've done I've actually done that before
what you do uh you know the chef mario
batali yeah the italian chef he uh he
was hanging out at at Danny's bar in
Chicago uh and I didn't like you know
I'm a big fan of his but I didn't like
fanboy out I just walked up to him and I
thought it'd be cool to just ask him uh
hey man do you get a lot of ass cuz
you're in awesome cuz you're a celebrity
chef and he just raised his a ring
finger up he says I'm married yeah he
didn't want to have that discussion he
might have been a spot might have been a
spice and buys wider sunlight and that
fallen for this anymore
got the ring right here dad here buddy
yeah he was to you his smash to like he
was when he walked out I think like two
people kind of like caught him mm-hmm
I [ __ ] was getting and then yeah
that was in the he didn't want to talk
to me just by himself getting drunk that
was his deal yeah at Danny's right
but anyways cuz I thought maybe you know
was it chilled dive bar yeah nobody's
gonna ask me no dumb [ __ ] here if you
sold chill
Tony jenandtony trip come up with it how
you be [ __ ] I bet you make it soufflés
and [ __ ] on days make us souffles
[ __ ]
[Music]
no get the [ __ ] out of him
I'm married what the [ __ ] going on in
here I'm drunk
this is mascara we get in here yeah yeah
so I mean I wouldn't asked him that
before like he was about to go on camera
and right before the you know action I
wouldn't have been like do you get a lot
of [ __ ] but he was at the bar getting
drunk I said I thought maybe there's a
good time to have this conversation sure
yeah time and place so we saw uh who's
that Omar Suleiman Suleiman Suleiman
Omar Suleiman well it was a weird big
deal walk into yes off jump cause it was
that Omar Suleiman Omar Suleiman very
live show very energetic and musical so
Omar Suleiman the entire it went before
I live did his thing it was a well known
Omar Suleiman then Todd live DJ went on
and then I went on and did a quick set
yeah it's a weird response it was a good
response but it was a weird yeah
responses I walk out there and I say it
was going on mold fast and it was a and
I said I'm Hannibal Burres maybe
lighting was bad baby's bad lighting
maybe I'm just a nondescript necklace
[Laughter]
but ya did a quick set the crowd for
outdoor music festival that was as good
as a crowd can get but you talking about
after Omar Suleiman where yeah his
energy his music was very high-energy
people with dance and so right before
that Suleiman
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah
yes so he was
and it was those songs are long yeah
also over long it because I was I we
were backstage kind of listening and
just up in the same song that long
yeah and he just kind of just go
straight through and energy people were
vibing out especially if you don't know
his music or just that style of music in
general you know it's like when people
aren't into like like instrumental metal
yeah every song sounds the same right so
that's how it was for us we just it was
in the background and we didn't know
when and then he was speaking another
language yeah so it's like you know the
song
I don't always sang in this course yeah
so he does his thing I go on for a few
minutes to crowd was very attentive for
that type of for that type of vibe and
uh that you know energy people listen it
was at this music festival jokes did a
couple things introduced I lips I lived
as his thing was a great great night
great way to kick off a festival mmm-hmm
hung out for a little bit did we go out
yeah we hadn't saw peanut butter wolf
peanut butter wolf yeah oh yeah and then
that's when the night gets fuzzy moving
along Friday yeah that's when I had to
get up in the morning cuz I had my
synthesizer workshop it's writing well I
built my own mo synthesizer it was a
class car wet it's called what something
from another mother
right drummer from another mother
drummer from another mother he was kind
of hating a little bit I was eight yeah
I was a little angry
well why because here's the thing when
we saw the schedule yeah
the way the schedule was worded it said
okay you guys are gonna do this workshop
and I was like this is gonna be the best
part of the festivals and building a
synth cuz it was a bill your own synth
workshops sure so we walk in and they
say Hannibal Eason over there Hannibal
said Stalin I'm like where's my seat and
they're like we don't got a seat for you
and they didn't have any extra kits it's
very upsetting I didn't see extra kid
next I know that's where I went I saw I
went and sat in that scene there lady
now now get up get up get up yeah I
don't know what the deal was I don't
know that they're just hating on me
because they don't know what was I don't
know
anyways so me and Hannibal start go we
started building the first part where
you're like snapping in the buttons and
whatnot right and I've done this many
times before because they used to do
circuit bending and all that stuff I'm a
big nerd with this stuff and I like
Legos and I just started going you going
crazy going like a madman and it wasn't
that easy for me and you cannon was
going really fast yeah you just like
we're like oh man you just kind of like
pushing my hand away you're like hold on
man
well to Vance is why I did that it was
because they were filming me yeah for
PBS I'm doing a piece on me and some
other people in there yeah and so it's
bad look if you they're doing all the
the work if you do it all that [ __ ] I
just got in the zone
and I know it's a bad look at these like
animals here at his workshop but he
ain't doing [ __ ] so that's when I saw
you was getting a hit like I wanted I
needed your help to make that [ __ ] but
you were just really good into it yeah I
mean I guess you're gonna make it man it
was it let me get some shots of me
putting stuff in there I mean just get
maybe if we'll give him a few minutes of
footage of me doing stuff and then you
could be go back to being this Speedy
Gonzales [ __ ] but you ended up doing it
fine yourself yeah it was it was
relaxing and you know gots a soldering
got the solder and soldering I never
done that you never soldered before
never soldered anything it's pretty fun
right it's the fuel started getting so
me I'm solder for a couple hours they
didn't give us any masks or none which I
feel like I started feeling light-headed
but that might have been cuz I was
hungover - but nah I mean the solder
plus a hangover I just you know what I
do it I just kind of like when I when I
solder I exhale like like that on to the
solder so the fume doesn't get in my
face I have like a tight
I've done it so many times I yeah I have
a technique for it so I know how to do
it without less interesting I would I
wish you would have said a boat to blow
out so you don't get solder who knows
what what's happening in my notes now
cuz it has solder that I got in there
yeah but it was uh it was relaxing
solder and just made stuff kinda zoning
out working on that it was really cool
and just kind of working on the
soldering and and in the class was over
it's a two-part class and to just be
able to like make a drum I mean here's
the thing is that mogh is not known for
making drum machines they've never made
a drum machine and the fact that the
workshop was based around a drum machine
was crazy to me that's why I was really
excited yeah you know that's also I was
very disappointed that I couldn't
participate in it well [ __ ] happens man
yeah well uh I forgive him they took
good care of us
it's a great care of us forget that's an
experience of workshop yeah how much was
it 50 no two dollars fifty well I mean
that makes sense I mean one of those
sins would cost close to there really I
wouldn't say that sin would cost fifteen
honor that one would cost probably more
like eight seven eight hundred wait wait
um what a workshop when I was the with
the with that you get admission into the
festival and everything oh if that works
out yeah it's totally at the respite
wristband in an air fest engineer you
get cert it was certain VIP things for
the table near tear yeah that's totally
worth it I would have paid fifty on for
that yeah yeah definitely definitely
they kind of gave me the artist discount
they get a say I might just give me this
is a lot of artists man you know yes sir
just give me some weed and I got you it
it was uh is really gratifying doing it
come in on a second day
yeah finished it up yeah Marcus helped a
little bit with the construction but I
did a lot of the work
yeah and and then we mess with the
machines in class and it was coke to jam
out with everybody so your share work no
problems mmm you [ __ ] work no problem no
problems
gotcha did it low they had to do a
little well solder and cleanup work well
besides that in those short circuits
none of that [ __ ]
I got a function in drama from another
mother synthesize it and I don't yeah
nice I don't know what I'm gonna do with
it make beats that that thing is not is
weird
it's more like um like a sequencer kind
of a it's not like this thing where you
can just you don't I'm saying is more
like a sequencer thing so you got to
really get into step sequencing and then
figure out how to it's it's a little bit
more of a complicated drum machine than
just yeah I but you boy you were playing
with some electronic drums you're you
kept kept coming back to that drum set
yeah it was uh this company was their
name they do sensory drum sensory
electric drums or something I can't
remember and it was uh it was really fun
and they looked cool and it was a quick
product and it felt good man
yeah you kept coming back to it yeah one
slice to it it's just it was just it
felt just a difference so it was just
physical like rubber pads right on a
real drum pads on the drum and they kind
of just pick up the noise and just you
could alter it based on how hard you hit
the drum yeah
and it was I want to get those when I
when I come on filming is movie in the
summer I'm gonna set up studio space in
Chicago for the podcast and also for
music [ __ ] too yeah yeah man next step
that's just sounded ultra smooth - yeah
it was I really had to keep myself from
getting it right there just cuz I knew
if I got it right there I wouldn't be
able to use it right away just because
of the travel schedule but it was a cool
fastest you bought a synthesizer some
what I bought a sampler it's like a
sampler
it's like sue snow cool yeah it's as
some gurus well I don't have it on me
now I can't so I haven't learned how to
use the exam at that time to [ __ ] with
it but it's a the company called
critters and Guitar II and they make
this awesome
it's it's a it's like this weird little
machine with wood buttons but it does a
bunch of stuff it could be like a
synthase but you know at the end of day
it's a real intelligent sampler and I
also bought the video component won't
make some sampler intelligent and what
follow-up question what makes a sampler
stupid well I guess it depends on how
cookie cutter a sampler can get like
there's certain samplers that can just
only do certain things and then this one
there's like a whole community based
around this synthesizer called the
organelle that make patches that are
based specifically for this sampler so
the sampler is basically like there's
like a whole community that works around
the sampler so this sampler is like made
by the people not just the engineers the
engineers physically made it but it's
the people that make this sampler what
it is and why it's dope okay that makes
sense the best way I can explain it not
really but I feel like if not for me in
my brain is that sample it might be too
intelligent for me but I'm sure some of
the listeners are like I know what he's
talking about I don't quite know 100
like I said I haven't from what I'd with
it a little bit and then the guy just
gave me the real quick rundown and I was
like I all I know is that I need to have
this in my life so when I get home and
play with it I'll have a better
explanation
[Music]
[Music]
get $30 off my name is allowed the
battle shaves Justin when you visit deep
baby dot-com / baby let's get baby drops
[Music]
[Music]
it's always really fun to just go around
and play with a different interesting
instruments I found especially on Sunday
after rocking out on the drugs and
messin with the new synthesizer that I
have a couple other things I genuinely
felt my brain yeah operating in a
different way yeah that happens like
especially that's happened to me like
when I used to work on beats like like
constantly in my studio like yeah when
you when you're just playing with since
all day it's just like the electricity
everything just hitting you like you
feel weird it makes you feel you might
even get anxiety and like I would I
would be in a long studio session then I
go and just go to get cigarettes at the
Food Mart and just talking to the
cashier would be like weird you know I
would just feel like a like robotic
almost like it's like it [ __ ] with your
head it messes with you I had the
opposite feeling where I fell on Sunday
I felt more articulate oh you fell
sharper I felt sharper I've no words
came to me easier Oh
easier time talking to strangers yeah I
just felt smooth and then we did the
comedy set later and I felt better on
stage like I felt quicker on stage you
know in a general sense I can I can
understand that because I feel like
maybe you unlocked some parts of your
brain that you don't that you never
really used yet maybe that did something
but I'm talking like literally walking
outside of a long session yeah just yeah
and you just you don't feel normal right
but I understand where you're coming
from - you're probably just your brain
probably was just like hey we're using
parties that we've never used before
yeah it was I felt yeah I felt really
good Sunday night we did a last-minute
show yeah that was great last-minute
show was great sold out in 20-something
minutes
yeah partially because we set the ticket
price really low to $10.00 kind of yeah
you know uh it was fun know we had some
a colas yeah that heckle was like a
weird like privileged heckle - it wasn't
you know what I'm saying like it was
just like I'm gonna say something
because I have the privilege to say this
the girl that said check your misogyny
yeah yeah what is they keep working it
out know what she said later again yeah
when I but I she said it again during
the nail what did you how did she say it
the first time said keep working out
that misogyny bro or something like yeah
yeah yeah and so which is you know with
that material I've been kind of
expecting that yeah or that type of yeah
reaction I've been expecting that even
though that's not the place that the
material comes from yeah I could see how
somebody could feel like you mean if
you're talking about women or what in
any way you being a misogynist so I was
kind of ready for I wanted to have the
discussion yeah and here why here why
she thought that in here what her you
know and then when I asked her I said
okay why do you feel that here's your
chance to explain yourself she just say
anything without completely dead Sam
dead silence so it's just what is that
what is that well you you have you you
want to say this big idea you want to
yell this thing in front of a room for
the people what's your goal do you
really want to have a discussion about
it or do you just want attention in a
moment or dgb did you think I wasn't
gonna address it in that way and be open
to discussion and you thought I was just
calling yell out
stupid [ __ ] shut up [ __ ] get this
[ __ ] out of here
I think it was just like I said
privilege I think she just felt like she
had the privilege to say that and do
that I don't know if it's privileged I
think it might have been just I don't
know maybe she really felt that but
didn't expect to have to you know expect
to be challenged to say a full light or
get roasted the [ __ ] out of for the rest
I mean and that's you roasted the [ __ ]
out of her net jerk my chain but that
was probably one of my favorite a
heckler situation yeah I've had just
because I was able to use it as a
through-line footage you had another guy
- and then you were kind of blending the
heckles yeah blended their reactions
into other jokes yeah it made me really
happy while I was doing it and because I
was playing the drums earlier what did
the guy say he said the guy yelled out
tell us about micro dosing with flour
yeah that's right that's right
it wasn't that we thought we just talked
about it's just talked about it the day
before also it wasn't that crazy like he
just gave me a little bit of acid and
some water
and I drank it and it was like okay I
feel a little bit different but it was
more like energized than it was yeah
well you never told me this story you
never you never told me that you
microdose on ass cuz it was nothing -
you know what I mean it wasn't like you
didn't feel anything
I felt something but net where I was
just out of my mind or some [ __ ] it was
just where I felt a bit energized maybe
a little more creative but NAT it wasn't
didn't take enough
I probably take enough but I felt I felt
it but it was it it wasn't crazy no but
it was it was fine we just we have made
beats for a little bit that's when I
made that weird drum beat oh yeah um and
I'll you taught me how to use Ableton a
little bit yeah it was cool yeah what so
that's it but the guy tell us about that
first of all I hate when people try to
make requests yeah
don't make requests as a DJ so as a DJ -
I hate that everybody just hates that
quest I can also just tell us about it
it's not that type of show yeah further
also you just pay you pay $10 shut up
yeah yeah definitely don't get to make
requests at the $10 show no I make a
request I request that this man be
removed from the bill yeah I mean but at
the same time um the $10 audience might
just be [ __ ] more reckless sure you
know how about that that maybe maybe I
should have maybe I should've waited it
out yeah I shoulda price yeah that's
what uh Daniel Tosh has a joke about I
did a show with him in Vegas and he has
a joke about sorry my tickets are so
expensive but it's just mostly cuz you
don't want to be around somebody dick or
what it's what he thought let's say $5
that's a great joke Jesus five $5 on the
ground this is for you great bit I like
that yeah but it was a it was a fun time
then we the show sold out so a lot of
the mold employees weren't able to get
in they asked us it's a DJ they're after
party after the DJ - after party we
agreed we agreed
I requested I requested a theremin yeah
which almost which almost didn't happen
why not well they because there was note
that you saw that that DJ booth was so
small there's nowhere to put it so we
ended up well first of all you weren't
there to see this part when when I was
first spinning
they had two big-ass two 12-inch
speakers stacks on the [ __ ] booth and
bass was hitting so hard that at one
point one of the stacks knocked over and
almost killed if I had someone standing
there would have killed them yeah it
fell over the edge did everybody gasp
finish it no I just I just played that
[ __ ] off I was I was just kind of like
dancing then I pushed it back on and
then one of the guys saw it it wasn't
even a worker or anybody like the guess
is one guy saw it came up there put
shove like a towel underneath it it was
all good but that's where the theremin
was it was on top of that thing Oh was
his whole was on top of a to stack
speaker so it was like probably like
what a foot and a half above our heads
uh-huh yeah
so it was it was kind of a goofy
situation where the theremin was placed
right you know he was but it kind of it
added to it definitely made the show way
more epic cuz every type animal would go
to it the theremin it look like he was
someone in the rain guys it was funny
because you started DJ him to
accommodate the theremin we got to do
that more often that was very good
Durham is a loose a city man it's a
quote Al Jackson citizen it was fun all
the times I went out during the festival
people with dancing and having a good
time and it was just lively energy yeah
and that motor cold place we played I
played there before and I liked that
venue I like to set up of it I like that
the little bleachers on yeah I the sound
there was great yeah that was a great
spot yeah a little outdoor area like
everything about that venue is awesome I
think that's gonna be the spot when we
play Durham
they gave us a great cut of the door
nice enough for that shoutout for that
great cut sometimes you sometimes you
pack out a place yeah and then you see
the numbers afterwards and you say what
in tarnation happened here I've
literally seen you forehead slap after
getting handed a piece of paper
literally see you like like to settle
the settlement paper come in you're just
like all kinds of weird costs and weird
file is it just so very on on a venue
and these places they have that built in
some places have the house nut is what
they'll call it what a house nut is this
what it cost to do business in the
building yeah that day so they'll have
the rent in their security guard if
there's a theatre and so yes sometimes
the house nut is some just arbitrary
[ __ ] yeah based on the relationship
they have with an artist or not because
I've learned that you know [ __ ] really
varies you know venues I've played for
years that [ __ ] is gone you know my all
of a sudden the percentage I can get
from them goes up as time goes along so
it's been times without made the
contract gets better it works better
better I got you with places that I have
a long relationship with you know
obvious yeah but yeah it's been times
where I sold a building out and I look
at the sheet and then I [ __ ] get sad
cuz I'm like this is not yet I expected
there's so many [ __ ] cost and then
with the you know we do the video stuff
that [ __ ] the range but the rains on
that [ __ ] sometimes they'll see they
they'll say oh we got that we have the
video screen in the house you're good
and then sometimes they'll say also have
a projection and video screeners it'll
be $2,000 I'm like can I get some
consistency please like they had the
screen and nails 150 bucks and it could
have had a
projector for free of some but that's
just bare it just wildly varies that
[ __ ] is bananas I talked I was talking
Bandos somebody's manager I was talking
to about that well I was talking to
tortoise about that when we're in
Brisbane I was like well I was like cuz
I remember seeing them do awesome
visuals and stuff when they play in
Chicago why don't you guys do the
projector stuff he's like out of all the
costs like renting and drum whole drum
kits [ __ ] amps whatever you can think
of the most expensive expense is a
goddamn [ __ ] projector yeah why why
and then he was even just like I don't
know why like I haven't no one knows why
the projector is such a [ __ ] costly
expense I don't know when it is you know
how it but it's just is so all over the
place where I'm well you know in the
interest of time we said have them just
get whatever but are you shopping around
for the best deal
do they just know that performers that
you know want or have a projection that
projection in this show really need a
projection so they able to just charge a
preview and what I think that's what it
is it's up that's probably like a union
thing just using you for all the cash
they can get that's that's my theory
it'd be three grand sometimes it just
doesn't make sense to charge that much
for a [ __ ] projector it just doesn't
make sense
yeah that's three that's what probably
what it costs like you could buy that
projector every time you rent it yeah it
doesn't make sense
i yo i tears almost started coming out
of my eyes when i just thought about how
much I spent on projection this past
tour up a little bit as my listeners
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
spoiled baby we each other oh you paid
three thousand for your projector I
don't have $3,000 I'm sorry
that was that's one of my problem you
can't take my problems away from me no
that's a goddamn problem everybody lives
different lives different
my life right now I think about
projection costs all the time yeah like
imagine if you had to pay a hundred
dollars every time you want to watch TV
[Laughter]
yeah but most fast would close it out DJ
that party because now it's a heavy
festival season Oh heavy festival season
we had all we would say we were in Miami
before that yeah Miami was interesting
to say the least
Miami gig was interested we played this
venue we left unnamed but if you are
just a halfway competent at the internet
you can find out what it was great sound
of this venue
cool staff at this venue they were very
welcoming they had all of my liquor and
snacks backstage
everything was nice they had security
walked me in they made sure we got out
they took care of my parents they said
everybody cool the crowd was energetic
almost everything was perfect about this
except the [ __ ] lights were
[ __ ] up the lights the lights the
lights I couldn't believe this [ __ ] I
it was the worst lighting situation I've
experienced in 15 years and a
professional show it was unbelievable
the stage itself was unbelievable but
the lights were just too lights on
either side of me on the speakers on the
speakers there weren't the fans no
layering into my goddamn peripheral
vision making was my whole equilibrium
up it was those LED lights - you know
where it's not just a spotlight it's
like a bunch of little lights right into
the corners of my eyes and so I had to
stand in the middle of them just to be
somewhat visible and I couldn't like who
- they weren't even hitting you from the
front they were hitting you exactly on
the side on the side of my
whoo but I get that you guys don't do
comedy that often but you get the this
[ __ ] is not rocket science like put some
[ __ ] that faces the stage some lights to
just face the stage all they needed to
do is go into those rack things and then
boil
it's just simple just put some lights
like what like who-who vetted that and I
kind of told you earlier today I was
like I feel like something about to be
off with this we should yeah but when I
was Sanchez during the day I remember
yeah so I wasn't even [ __ ] with
lights cuz I couldn't see the lights
what it wasn't even like an issue it was
like okay they probably got these lights
like I didn't that's the last thing I
looked over at was like yeah oh there's
lights on top of these speakers and
that's how I was going down yeah it was
the projection that I was worried about
the most you know it's the video and
crowds credit it still was very live I
did know the show was fine the show all
right
I did go hard on the lights yeah it was
very
I I wish I wish we had pictures of the
venue or the show right now like from I
think I have a picture yeah I think I
sent you a picture then I think you
responded with hikes well no that's
without me onstage it was it was just
whatever though it was the show well
thanks to everybody in Miami that came
through next time I'll be back in a
properly lit professional venue yeah
Baywatch premiere it was the next day
you know a mock Baywatch premiere in
Miami I flew the birds family down my
mom and dad kicked it in Miami for the
first time
Baywatch for me I wore a blue suit a
blue Zara suit xyron's I when I got them
with a goddamn collarless with a
colorist Zara
blue sir it was a good look at that
house flowers Flyers of [ __ ]
yeah I was fly outs flies a [ __ ]
pull pull Shannon Shannon can you pull
up me at the Baywatch premiere break
watch the red carpet god dammit
I was looking goddamn fresh with a
goddamn it was it was a very reasonably
priced budget fly look I made you queue
actually that really yeah thanks I'm AG
cute they said I'll check out Hannibal
he chose to go with the collarless shirt
yeah the banded collar is the look I'm
rockin one right now that's the look
yeah that's what you got a hell of
search like that Kevin I've been on this
way for like two years now my [ __ ] I got
a lot of shirts like that I got maybe
like 39 like 20 nice 20 oh yeah collars
no more man like collar you don't have
to pop collars no more that's mine DS
you just let the collar ride mm-hmm you
know I'm saying all right so uh it was a
good time to move the premiere the
premiere was a goddamn spectacle the the
red carpet yeah I didn't go it
he's probably I mean they had a lounge
where they had some free drinks and
stuff yeah but uh it was it was crazy
man it was it was on the beach it was on
the beach it was uh it was just it was
it was insane he had a live feed up to
MTV or something with a couple thousand
people out there it was one of the
craziest hottest [ __ ] though wouldn't it
it was it was pretty humid as Miami yeah
you were in a full suit and okay you
didn't like [ __ ] soak yourself nah
man cool as [ __ ] rockin linen shirt Oh
was linen that linen my shirt was linen
the suit was fitted what's it a Baywatch
for me you know how I'm getting it dry
cold some liquor check on something
[Music]
yeah it was uh it was a fun time though
man yeah I I've been spoiling the movie
but I don't think I want to do it on it
that's been my thing has been spoiling
the I'm not really spoiling the movie
though you're not you're just spoiling
your I'm spoiling my part well I think
it's really that much of a spoil I think
it's a solid marketing technique I think
so too
I die in a movie I'd I'm Baywatch yeah
huh when it happened to because I was at
the premiere premiere and I I was the
only one that just yelled out oh hell no
[Laughter]
what what I knew I was gonna die yeah
but even still when you see yourself
dead you're a oh man I didn't like that
still don't like it yeah you're not
prepared for it my body my body just
couldn't handle it either in the movie
theater after I dare if I after I died
in a movie
I just went to sleep just took a nap
that's just it was just like I couldn't
that's a handle chaos and pressure I'll
just sleep just sleep it off just slept
that [ __ ] off that's how I do it too if
i if I'm if I'm under a lot of stress I
just take a nap lay down relax and then
get my life back together
yeah Tony I got a question for you so do
you think you go to a restaurant and you
don't they give you the chips and salsa
right yeah I say you only have couples
chips you know they take them back you
think reals you think they reuse those
chips you think they throw em out
there's definitely some spots they reuse
them chips yeah definitely but then
there's some spots that don't most spots
I would say don't but there's definitely
some spots that do
yeah cuz that's what cuz I cuz I won't
cause the food usually Mexican food you
know comes pretty fast yeah
so you if you like the chips yeah you
can I have to you doing I'm like that's
a waste of chips but also should they be
doing that I don't know
should they be they shouldn't I mean I'm
almost 100% sure that that's like a
health code violation to reuse the chips
sure there's lots of code violations out
there fam
I know Market Market
all right I don't know if you uh work in
a restaurant and you have some insight
on this so if you worked at a Mexican
restaurant emailed a handsome Rambler at
gmail.com and will read this cuz I feel
like is half and half okay well then how
if you I feel like bars if they don't
finish the peanuts at then then I feel
like they put the peanuts back in the
peanut jar well peanuts is Shales though
but no I'm just saying like the
unshelled peanuts you know where the
mixed nuts in the in the bowl I feel
like they probably take all just throw
it right back in the jar oh that's
[ __ ] that's gross what do you wear
where do you draw the line that's my
question when somebody touches it it's
done well anyway I mean I guess one
thing as a human you gotta just try to
trust your immune system yeah and and
realize that you don't touch some gross
[ __ ] man yeah your life you go inhale
some gross stuff you know somebody gonna
take a [ __ ] and without washing their
hands thoroughly and shake your hand if
you're into shake your hands
mm-hm and you just try not to have all
that all these gross things
I haven't in the back of your mind at
the forefront of your mind whoever get
us
you ever get us thinking Mike yeah isn't
that the worst use the word the bad
breath mike is I think pretty much a lot
of Mike so if you talk about artists
over the years so like just slobbering
and yelling and breathe it over Mike
yeah I've definitely got us thinking
Mike after comedy show it like when I'm
sound chicken and that's I'll tell the
[ __ ] I like you need to replace
that Mike yeah that Mike stinks our dip
it in some [ __ ] Clorox be a goddamn
professional can you dip a mic in
Clark's God do so know you could take
the shell off and can replace the phone
okay you don't say but you could
definitely yeah just [ __ ] take the
thing off and replace it just throw it
out there's no fixing that [ __ ]
it [ __ ] smells like bad breath
that'll ruin the performance for me if I
did stand-up comedy I kept smelling
somebody's funky ass breath that would
ruin my rhythm yeah you know I've had it
where where the mic stunk but I just
power through power because the people
the people don't deserve that you're a
better man than I am
you gotta just tell the jokes or you
gotta talk about that Mike that's how
you do that's how you deal with the pain
everybody I don't know if you could tell
but I'm going through some [ __ ] right
now this this microphone is disgusting
but I'm gonna power you know and do this
for y'all I got a funny story I remember
Carbondale there is this band that was
playing was and there was some kind of
issue with the mic were like the
electricity like something was having
with the electricity current and uh Mike
Schadt shocking face oh really
something was going on so I get me to
get closer like this weird face but you
didn't know it the moment through
[Laughter]
I'm fine now we all just thought he was
being a weird-ass singer yeah cuz
singers you know make them weird faces
and and guitarists they got their music
face every time you pull up to the mic
he would do that as like that's like his
thing he does it but it was just like
him getting Chuck [ __ ] yeah man
it's dangerous
he's more so he just powered through
powered through that [ __ ] no pun
intended
well the line intended a boat have you
wanna take yeah he powered however you
want to take it that [ __ ] is a
pro what man was he from I don't
remember it was some college I don't
even know open mics in the city book
gigs in the country coming through you
see Mike shocked me in my ranks me yeah
man I having a good time that festival
was I can't wait another year for mock
fest man yeah I think that's how that's
how dope it was that is bad is
definitely the type of festival and you
know he'd the workshop when you were
doing the workshop that was great was
that it like a nine-year-old girl next
to you yeah what her father when I saw
that I was like this is how I would bond
with my child right like Bill the
[ __ ] synthesizer with a nine year old
girl yeah that was really nice it was
really cool to see that was really cool
to see they were having a good time well
you have a [ __ ] cool as dad yeah you
don't even know right now how cool your
[ __ ] dad is ten years from now you're
gonna be like my dad [ __ ] took me to
a Mofaz to build a goddamn synthesizer
I think they went last year - really
that from what some of the mole people
told me they yeah unless I'm making up
something I'm also a liar did she see it
like I wasn't really watching it but
this she seemed like she knew her [ __ ]
or did it seem like she was bored or no
she was into it yes she was really into
it the whole time and she knew her [ __ ]
you think I mean I didn't talk music
theory with her yeah but she seemed like
she knew what she wanted to watch her
soldering skills it looked like she was
on point and her dad was helping a
little bit but she was doing most of the
work it was it was cool ya know ya know
what a good activity to do with your
child it was also fun to be in a
classroom dynamic I haven't been in that
class with people in a while and
soldiers too haven't you know your
classmates you talk a little trash with
and I was late I was a little late to
the second session on Sunday I came in
about 3:15 it started at 3:00 there was
this girl behind me a track girl is a
producer named see that all look who
made it to class you know my life yeah
you did say that when we were first the
first day we were walking cuz it was
more it was more as 10 a.m. yeah so we
were walking over like at 9:30 and you
were like oh man who's crazy feels like
we're going to class yeah yeah yeah we
let me literally worry yeah wonder what
I'm gonna make with it I'm super excited
to get that drum [ __ ]
the drum the sensory drums and my
organelle I mean it'll start a new band
we'll call it call it call it a band
tidal power nope turtle power
no that's stupid what we call it been uh
[Music]
leave it out to the listeners if you got
suggestions for our band name yeah the
handsome ramble at gmail.com what do you
want to go with at least
guideline like a 1 that one word name
two word how many a one-word name two
word name if you if you guys are sitting
in suggestions don't sit in a stew
with suggestion like of based on our
ethnicities would have liked Cosby black
and yellow but Louis think I got so
stupid direct message I told you about
was that
that's stupid DM that I got about about
how someone legit thought that we were
brothers
oh yeah yummy you want me to read it
yeah so I got this dumb DM on my instant
my from my IG and this was the message
oh by the way this person never
responded back but it was okay here this
is what he said
so hey Tony big handsome Rambla fan
quick question my friend told me you and
Hannibal are half-brothers like you
share a biological parent and Hannibal
is half Korean and that's why his eyes
are like that [ __ ] I told him that he
might be semi races but they assist it's
true are you guys brothers and then Al
Jackson gave me the idea of explaining
saying that it is true but explaining
the plot of bloodsport yeah to him
replied with well the rumor is halfway
true we aren't biological brothers but
my father raised him like his son my
father is a fifth degree black belt in
Hapkido and when we were in elementary
school he caught hannibal trying to
steal very expensive collectible sword
from our living room instead of calling
the police he offered him a deal what
kind of a deal well I didn't have a
training part of my head so he thought
it would be beneficial for both of us to
learn together so yes and no I haven't
seen bloodsport so that makes it even
funnier you'll never see bloodsport and
a wild not enough to get if I saw that
to get that is the plot of bloodsport
yeah it's the beginning of bloodsport
yeah yeah
all right no respite he never responded
back so he did see it it showed up as
seen yeah yeah but he probably was like
this [ __ ] he probably yeah he
probably knows bloodsport that's the end
[Music]
I yeah yeah all right
[Music]